Ich sag mal so.
Ganz wertfrei.
Völlig wertfrei.
Nein, nein.
Jetzt müssen wir da doch ein paar Fragen angehen, die ich unbeantwortet gelassen haben wollte.
Es wäre wertfreier gewesen, wenn du einfach drüber hinweggegangen wärst.
Ganz wertfrei. Völlig wertfrei. Völlig wertfrei. Einen wunderschönen guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Mit Stefan und Florenton. Richtig. Und der dritte im Bunde, Adrian. Vielen Dank für dieses herrliche Intro. Da sind direkt ein paar Lächeln, ein paar Lachelfelden auf die Lippen. Ein paar Lachelfelden? Lachelfelden. Lachelfelden. Okay. Ich muss immer noch auftauchen. Ich war ja gefroren die ganze Woche. Karbonit eingefroren. Karbonit eingefroren. Jetzt entdecke die Welt gerade wieder. Alles ist so hell, alles ist so laut, meine Sinne sind noch gar nicht richtig angestellt. Platons Höhen-Gleichnis. Au! Ich könnte Platons Höhen-Gleichnis erhöhen, erfüllen. Ach, du bist so laut immer, du bist immer so viel. Man bräuchte immer so eine Light-Version von dir, so eine 30% weniger Stefan. Das ist das Schlimmste, was jemand gesagt hat, glaube ich. Wie gemein. So ein Light-Produkt, so Stefan Light, einfach mal so einen Ticken runter bräuchte ich mal von dir.
Das ist wie zu sagen, oh, eine Brille steht dir richtig gut, im Sinne von, dann sieht man weniger von deinem Gesicht.
Kleine winzigen Augen sind größer.
Du bist ein bisschen too much, ist auch so, eigentlich mag man dich nicht, wie du bist.
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch, also es gibt ja Qualität und Quantität. Und Qualität bist du, also, also wirklich, also wirklich, wirklich so komplett. Aber Quantität hast du ein Problem, du hast ein Mengenproblem, du bist einfach zu viel.
Aber gut, das ist wie wenn du halt so eine richtig geile Lasagne hast, aber einfach, du siehst schon von Anfang an, das ist einfach eine Menge. Ja, aber vielleicht liegt es an dir, dass du zu oft exposed bist, der Lasagne jetzt, also mir. Ach so. Weil du könntest mich ja auch in Dosen vertragen. Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass wir uns diese Woche häufiger gesehen haben. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Also einmal häufiger, ich finde es jetzt nicht wirklich viel zu viel. Für dich ist das wahrscheinlich schon jetzt Clusterfuck und wir hängen zu oft aufeinander. Vielleicht mache ich dich mal leiser ein bisschen. Hattest du mal, ja genau, das hilft vielleicht auch allen da draußen, aber hattest du mal so einen richtigen, so ein Aufeinanderhängen, wie nennt man das denn nochmal? Urlaub nennt man das gleich. Ja, Aufeinanderhängen, wo du wirklich so ein Gefühl hattest, du hältst jemanden nicht mehr aus. Ja, ständig.
Ständig, auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen natürlich auch immer,
Toiletten mein grösster Freund, auch immer so
in Rest, ich mag das liebste, wenn in ein Restaurant
die Toiletten so unten sind, wenn man
nochmal in so einen Kellerraum geht, wo man so ein bisschen
Schatz, bist du wieder auf dem Klo?
Ich wollte mal jetzt fragen,
warum du nicht rauskommst, weil du bist jetzt
streng genommen, wir sind im Restaurant seit zwei Stunden, du warst seit anderthalb Stunden, warst du da vorne auf dem Klo, deswegen wollte ich mal, Schatz, bist du noch da drin? Ja, ich musste hier noch kurz, die Fliesen, wir wollten noch das Bad machen, dachte ich, guck mir mal die Fliesen hier an. Du bist zu Hause auch nur die ganze Zeit auf dem Klo. Genau, ich dachte, vielleicht können wir die Fliesen übernehmen von hier, die sind so schön. Weil das Essen ist jetzt gekommen. Ich bin doch gleich wieder da. Weil jetzt kam das Steak an. Es wird nämlich jetzt auch kalt. Kannst du mir einen kurzen Moment Ruhe geben, bitte? Kannst du mir in diesem Kündchen ein bisschen... Du, wenn du nicht mit mir zusammen sein willst, dann sag das. Ich dachte eh, dass du heute mit mir Schluss machen willst, da draußen. Ich dachte, ich... Das Fenster. Hä? Klemmerst du gerade aus dem Fenster heraus? Ja, was ist dann die Toilette nach der Toilette? Ja, ja, ich glaube das Fenster. Garten, draußen sein, Leuchtturminsel. Keine Leuchtturminsel. Deswegen biete ich mich immer an, einkaufen zu gehen. Ich brauche jemand was, ich gehe einkaufen. Nein, nein, ich brauche niemand was. Ach so, okay. Gar nichts, nicht mal irgendwie Taschentücher oder so. Jeder braucht immer was. Niemand hat nie, gar kein Bedürfnis. Nee, Wunschlos glücklich, ich habe gerade meine Taschentücher, meine Minz, kleine Minz. Wie viele Printstifte hast du noch in der Schublade? Zwei Printstifte, Printstifte. Hast du Schraubenzieheraufsätze? Genug. Schraubenzieheraufsätze? Ja. Ein Schraubenzieheraufsatzpaket Set? Zum Beispiel, guck mal, da haben wir doch was, da haben wir doch was, bring dir mit. mit. Kannste besorgen. Brich dir mit. Ich habe ein Riesenproblem, ich muss heute noch auf die Suche gehen, und zwar, ich weiß nicht, also ganz kurz, Thema Schrauben. Ja, hol es mal alle rein. Hol es mal alle mal kurz rein. Ich mache mal den großen Themenmagnet an. Ich habe das Gefühl, du willst nur Dinge einfach loswerden. Ja, ich muss nicht mehr von der Seele reden, du bist der Einzige, mit dem ich rede sonst, deswegen muss ich das sagen. Du hast gerade gesagt, ich bin zu viel.
Ich habe ja Zivildienst gemacht, so.
Das wissen wir alle, du musst nicht da anfangen.
Mit Kindern doch, so.
Ach Gott, fange ich da an.
Gehen zurück ins Jahre 2011.
Ja, why?
Fang mit letzter Woche an.
Und da hieß es, so, pass auf, wir brauchen ein Schild, die Leute wissen nicht, was wir hier machen.
Wir brauchen ein Schild draußen an der Tür, auf dem steht, was wir machen.
Es kommen ständig Leute und sagen, kann ich hier mein Fahrrad reparieren, kann ich hier Schl hier machen. Wir brauchen ein Schild draußen an der Tür, auf dem steht, was wir machen. Es kommen ständig Leute und sagen, kann ich hier mein Fahrrad
reparieren, kann ich hier Schlüssel machen?
Nein!
Aber ist es so, dass wenn
nicht klar benannt ist, draußen an dem Gebäude,
was dringend passiert, dass andauernd
Menschen reinkommen? Ich hätte gern
zwei Kugeln in der Waffel, einmal
Schokolade und einmal Pfeffer.
Ich muss dich hier stoppen. Sie sind ja der dritte Mensch, der hier reinkommt. Das ist eine Versicherungsfirma. Ach so, weil nichts dran stand. Dann bin ich davon ausgegangen, dass es eine Eisdiele ist. Wieso gehen Sie von irgendwas aus? Warum kommen wir noch Menschen rein? Das würde sich gut anbieten hier in der Ecke. Wir haben nicht immer ein Schild, wo Eis steht. So, und deswegen musste ich ein Schild draußen anmachen. Keine Eisdiele.
Keine Eisdiele, keine Erotikmassage, wir kümmern uns hier um eure Kinder.
Und dann hat mein Chef mir was ganz Besonderes gesagt.
Keine Erotikmassage, wir kümmern uns hier um eure Kinder?
Vertrauens erwecken.
Ja, ich finde es...
Oh, zu denen gebe ich gerne meine Kinder.
Es ist für mich immer ein Schmunzler, finde ich.
Immer wenn du an so einer Massage lokal vorbeigehst und da einfach
mit so ganz wütendem
Kindermassage
mit so ganz
Baby und Kindermassage
und
ich glaube nicht.
Kinder haben doch auch manchmal
muskuläre Probleme. Das stimmt, ja.
Oh, der Rücken, ich brauche jetzt auch mal wieder eine Massage. Aber werden die denn auch nur von Kindern massiert? Der Stadtcreep macht einen neuen Laden auf. Er hat endlich, da war irgendwie lange nichts los. Der Stadtcreep hat so lange nichts gemacht und so. Und dann sind alle froh, dass er jetzt wieder irgendwie ein Gewerbe angemeldet hat. Aber dann hängt er so das Schild auf und so. Es wird gelüftet, die Firma, die reinkommt, bringt das Schild an, er macht diese Silberfolie weg und überall bleibt Kindermassage.
Und der Antrag liegt so beim Stadtrat und alle so, es klingt illegal, aber ist es?
Also Bücher wurden durchwälzt.
Welches Gesetz genau wird hier gebrochen?
Gesetze wurden durchforstet. Es wird kein Gesetz gebrochen. Wir haben nicht das Massagegesetz, das MSTGB, sagt nichts über Alter aus. So, und deswegen, ich finde es immer lustig, dieses Keine-Erotik-Massage, immer so wirklich auf einem Zettel, der so drangeklebt wird, der gar nicht zum Design des Ladens passt, sondern offensichtlich spontan ausgedruckt wurde, genervt und dann drangehängt wurde.
Und ungefähr so haben wir dieses Schild gebraucht.
So, ich möchte ganz kurz darauf eingehen, weil ich habe einen sehr, behalt alle deine Gedanken, wir wollen da weitermachen, aber es ist auch ein Podcast, wo man andere kleine Gags einstreuen kann. Gerne, du, gerne. Weil mir ist, ich hätte neulich nämlich ein Interview gelesen, irgendwie auf Weiss oder so, über eine Masseurin.
Und dann wurde, das ist ein sehr langes Interview mit sehr vielen Fragen, dann wurde sie eine Frage gestellt. Was, wenn ein Massage-Patient, Klient, welches ich immer das nennt, eine Erektion bekommt? Und ich dachte, das wäre einigermaßen normal. Mhm. Und dachte mir, wir sind ja alle wahrscheinlich Profis und so, und wenn man halt nackt da liegt und berührt wird, kann das ja passieren. Und das war nämlich auch kurz bevor ich dann mal irgendwann massiert wurde. Und das hat mich so, ich dachte, ich war einigermaßen beruhigt, weil ich dachte, das ist angenommen, es passiert das Undenkbare. Wir sind alle Professionen, wir sind alle Erwachsene. Und dann hat sie aber geantwortet, nee, das geht gar nicht. Dann sagt sie dem Patienten ganz klar, er hat sich zu beruhigen, bitte beruhigen Sie sich, und dann verlässt sie den Raum. Was viele Leute sehr sexy finden. Bitte beruhigen Sie sich, schlägt ihr ins Gesicht, spuckt ihr in den Mund und geht dann aus dem Raum.
Und was? Ich fand das so schlimm.
Moment, und dann guckt sie... Sie bricht es ab, sie bricht die Massage ab.
Und wenn sie es nicht bessert, dann schickt sie den Patienten und schmeißt sie raum.
Moment, und sie guckt dann in der Minute nochmal rein, ob sie es gebessert hat?
Ich weiß nicht, aber muss man sie reinrufen oder sowas.
Aber das klang so schlimm.
Okay, Leute, ab jetzt, ich werde niemals eine Massage in Anspruch nehmen.
Weil ich dachte, das kann doch passieren, wenn dann irgendwie ein Oberschenkel massiert
Vielen Dank. Aber das klang so schlimm. Okay, Leute, ab jetzt, ich werde niemals eine Massage in Anspruch nehmen. Weil ich dachte, das kann doch passieren, wenn dann irgendwie ein Oberschenkel massiert wird oder so, keine Ahnung. Es kann doch wirklich passieren. Man soll sich ja auch entspannen. Ich dachte, es ist völlig, völlig Teil dieser Experience, unabhängig von den Rotikmassagen. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe es anders vorgestellt., ich habe es anders vorgestellt, dachte, es ist alles im Provisorium. Ich dachte auch, dass es, ja. Und sie sagt, bitte beruhigen Sie sich, verlässt den Raum. Ich würde im Erdboden versinken. Schrecklich. Furchtbar. Also es ist nicht mehr in meiner Comfortzone, die Idee, eine Massage zu bekommen. Ja, vor allem, du kannst ja jetzt gar nicht mehr entspannen, Du musst ja dann konstant an irgendwas denken, was dich irgendwie auf andere Gedanken bringt. Gibt es eigentlich sowas wie Anti-Viagra? Also gibt es so das Gegenteil-Viagra, dass dann gar nichts mehr geht? Es gibt auch Situationen im Leben, wo es nützlich wäre. MacDonalds. Ja, ja, auch nicht schlecht. Aber sowas wäre doch auch mal nützlich. Ich weiß nicht, ob es sowas gibt. Ja, gute Frage. Oder ob das einfach, ob die gesamte Evolution sagt, nee, Freundchen, da haben wir auch noch ein Wörtchen mitzureden. Verstärken ja, aber das kann man nicht ausschalten, vergiss es. Das alles, 280 Milliarden Jahre Evolution auf diesen Punkt, den kriegt ihr jetzt auch nicht weg. Die Natur sagt so, ich habe eine Aufgabe. Ja, genau. Erhaltung und Fortpflanzen. Nee, das geht nicht. Ich bringe doch nichts hervor, was euch eure Ständerchen wegnimmt. Nee, nee, nee. Ja gut, aber das fand ich ganz schlimm und da dachte ich mir so, klar, jetzt sehe ich aber auch diese keine Erotikmassage, die dann auch oft in All Caps dann da so stehen, sehe ich jetzt mit einem anderen Blick, mit so einem strengen, dann gehe ich raus. Patient hat sich zu beruhigen Modus. Naja, okay, wir waren bei deinem Kindermassageladen stehen geblieben. Und wie ist es beim Friseur? Also ist das da auch ein Problem? Deswegen kriegt man ja das große Cape. Ja, eben. Warum kriegst du bei der Massage nicht einfach ein Cape? Wieso ich dachte, das ist Reverse-Batman-Cape, nämlich nur vorne. Vorne und mit Ärmchen aber. Ich glaube, Batman hat keine Ärmchen. Das wäre mein Tipp, weil es gibt ja die neue Iteration jetzt schon wieder und immer ist das Kostüm ein bisschen anders. Ich hätte gerne mal dann wirklich so All-In-Cave vorne mit Ärmchen durchstehen. Aber ja, warum kriegt man nicht einfach ein Cape oder sowas da? Egal, schwierig. So, auf jeden Fall, ich sollte ein Schild draußen an, also ich habe zumindest gemacht in einer heilpädagogischen Tagesstätte, also da gehen Kinder an Nachmittag hin. Heilpädagogische Tagesstätte. Und da musste er das Schild ran. Und dann hat mein Chef folgendes gesagt. Du, nimm aber für das Schild nicht die normalen Schrauben, sonst schraubt das jemand wieder ab. Weil jeder liebt diese Schilder. Weil jeder will nicht so eine Kinderheilanstalt gründen. Sondern nimm die besonderen Sternschrauben. Sternschrauben? Und es gibt Sternschrauben, wo du halt nicht Kreuz oder Schlitz hast, sondern Stern. Und die Idee ist, dass du die mit einem normalen Schraubenzieher nicht aufmachen kannst. Wait a second, wait a second, wait a minute, wait an hour. Wie kriegst du die denn dann dran? So, ja, aber dann kriegt die ja jeder auch wieder ab. Und jetzt musst du nämlich in den Spezialladen und dir in Sternschrauben laden, die genau richtig... Keine Erotik-Sternschrauben! Musst du dir genau den richtigen Sternschrauber holen, um den ranzumachen. Aber haben die ihr Schild bei der Sternschraubenladen? Ja, ich verstehe das Problem. Du gehst rein und kaufst den Sternschraubenzieher. Dann gehst du raus und dann werde ich als Sternschraend. Ich verstehe schon. Die haben jetzt so eine Brezelschraube. Die haben alle Formen von den Lebkuchen durch. Die machen natürlich den Brezelschrauben. Mondschraubenzieher. Und dann habe ich den speziellen Sternenschrauber gebraucht. Und ich dachte mir, krass, das ist so eine geile Idee. Weil natürlich ist so ein Schild verwundbar. Weil die Tür ist zu, da brauchst du einen Schlüssel. Aber das Schild ist einfach nicht angreifbar, weil natürlich, es sind viele Kinder, da ist die Schule auch direkt daneben, die haben alle einen Schraubenzieher und die natürlich... Ich meine, die haben so Riesentonister, was soll alles in diesen riesigen Tonistern, die grösste sind als... Die versuchen, die alles abzuschrauben, was sich abschrauben lässt. Deswegen fand ich den Instinkt gut, zu sagen, lass uns die Hochsicherheitssternschrauben nehmen. So, jetzt skippen wir mal so 16 Jahre in die Zukunft. So Mad Mission Impossible-artige Laser, die davor einen Alarm auslösen. Jemand schraubt ihren Sternschrauben ab. Ja, ich habe mir beim Anschrauben richtig Mühe gegeben, das so richtig fest reinzudrehen und das dann auch nochmal in so einem Winkel, dass man da nicht gut ran kann. Und bis heute hängt dieses Schild. Ab und zu, wenn ich noch in der Heimat bin, fahre ich da vorbei und denke mir, yes. Stern schrauben. So, jetzt skippen wir mal 16 Jahre in die Zukunft. Danke. Und zwar jetzt in meiner Wohnung, ganz bescheuert, ist der Kühlschrank. Aber der Kühlschrank ist in dem Schrank, okay? Du bist der Kühlschrank. Doch der Schrank ist auch im Kühlschrank drin. Genau. Der Kühlschrank ist im Schrank. Ach so, ja. Wir haben jetzt einen Kühlschrank in dem Schrank zweiter Ordnung. So, und jetzt gibt es natürlich das Problem, dass die Schrankschrank und die Kühlschranktür gleichzeitig geöffnet werden müssen.. Das heißt, der Kühlschrank ist ein bisschen lose in dem Schrank drin und diese Türen sind so zusammengeschraubt. Und das System funktioniert schlicht nicht. Weil ich kriege es einfach nicht hin, egal wie ich es mache, dass der Kühlschrank wirklich zu ist. Der ist immer noch ein bisschen offen. Der Kühlschrank ist immer noch ein bisschen offen. Der Kühlschrank istht einmal mehr darauf an. Weil der Schrank, der Schrankschrank, wenn der zu ist, ist der Kühlschrank Schrank nicht ganz zu. Und dann denke ich immer, dann muss ich den Kühlschrank weiter rausziehen, dann geht das aber vom Winkel nicht mehr. Weil du hast ja, stell dir vor, wie unglaublich anspruchsvoll es ist, zwei Türen übereinander zu bauen, die ja andere Scharniere haben und in einem anderen Winkel und so ist alles ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schrecklich. Vor allem, man müsste ja meinen, dass da so ein bisschen Reibung auch entsteht, oder nicht? Weil die eine Tür ist ja anders und der Winkel der anderen ist ja nicht an dem gleichen Winkel wie der Tür. Und wo genau muss der Kühlschrank stehen? Muss der ganz links stehen oder ganz rechts? Horror, Ingenieur Horror. So, was dazu geführt hat, dass mein Kühlschrank quasi über Jahre nie richtig zu war. Wir erinnern uns jetzt, die aufmerksamen Hörer und Hörerinnen werden es wissen, an die krasse Stromrechnung, die Florian die bekommen hat. Auch hier kommt alles zusammen. Auch hier kommt alles zusammen. Vielen Dank, abgeschlossen. Und was so ein riesiges Problem war. Und jetzt war ich ein paar Wochen nicht in Köln, riesiges Problem und jetzt ist es eine Katastrophe, war alles voller Wasser, furchtbar. Und jetzt habe ich mir gesagt, weißt du was, fuck it, ich beende diese Scharade jetzt einfach, weil natürlich der Kühlschrank ist hässlich und deswegen steht er in einem Schrank, der sehr gut aussieht. Und ich dachte mir, Ästhetik, ich liebe, ich liebe Ästhetik. Du weißt, wie sehr meine Augen die Wonne pflegen, was Schönes anzuschauen. Aber ich dachte mir an dem Punkt, weißt du was, nein, ich werde diese Schranktür einfach abmontieren. Einfach weg damit und ich habe dann nur noch den Kühlschrank und der geht dann auch richtig zu. Und jetzt dachte ich mir, okay, wie schwer kann das sein? Und dann ist es ja irgendwie zusammengeschaut. Und ein alter Arc-Amp-Nemesis kommt jetzt ins Spiel. Und jetzt nehme ich die Verkleidung ab und was sehe ich? Die Sternenschrauben. Ich denke mir, Moment mal, hat da der Installateurmeister gesagt, du, pass mal auf. Nee, aber bring da mal, auch so ein Zevi, aber bring da mal die richtigen Schrauben an. Nicht, dass da Leute diese Schraube abnehmen. Nicht, dass die einfach so mir nichts dir nichts diese Schrauben rausdrehen können. Das wäre ja fatal. So, und jetzt habe ich genau das gleiche Problem wie diese kleinen Schüler, die jeden Tag das Schild klauen wollten. Ich brauche jetzt nämlich so einen Sternschrauber. Das heißt, ich werde die direkt nach der Aufnahme nochmal ziellos durch Köln streunen, weil ich nicht mal
einen Ansatz habe, muss man dazu
Schuster, Schlosser, Schlösser.
Mein Tipp wäre, jeder Baumarkt. Jeder fucking
Baumarkt. Ich bin ja hier in der
Metropol-Area. Ich habe doch
hier keinen Baumarkt mehr. Klasse Baumarkt.
Gibt es zig Baumärkte in Köln.
Auch so Innenstadtbaumärkte, die sind ein bisschen weird.
Aber jeder fucking Baumarkt wird doch so einen
Sternschrauber haben. So, und das ist jetzt meine Aufgabe für heute. Ich brauche Florentin Will und das Geheimnis des Sternenschraubers. Das ist meine Episode heute. Da freue ich mich ein bisschen drauf. Weil wenn mich die Reise in den Baumarkt führt, ich bin gerne in Baumärkten.
Ich bin auch gerne in Baumärkten.
Gerne unterwegs.
Was ist bei dir genau der Wille, in den Baumarkt zu gehen? Bei mir ist es der Geruch. Bei mir ist dieses, alle sind hier mit einem klaren Ziel, das mag ich auch, wenn Menschen ein klares Ziel haben, mag ich das gern, die sind alle so fokussiert, und dann wird mir wieder klar, alle haben ein komplexes Leben mit ihren kleinen shitty Problemen, und ich denke mir, also tagsüber denke ich mir auch, was macht ihr, was arbeitet ihr, dass ihr jetzt gerade tagsüber in so einem Baumarkt seid, habt ihr alle Podcasts? Das ist wie so ein riesiger Ameisenhaufen, wo die Ameisen außen ihr eigenes Ding machen und rumkrabbeln, aber im Ameisenhaufen treffen sich alle. Und man guckt, man nickt sich so zu und guckt sich an und dann der braucht, die Ameise kommt rein und so, Leute, ich brauche genau dieses eine Scharnierteil, zack und geht wieder raus. Und man denkt sich, was, in welcher Welt? In welcher Welt? Warum fehlt jetzt genau dieses eine Scharnierstück hier? Was ist da los? Wissen Ameisen von den Projekten der anderen Ameisen? Müssen sie ja. Die müssen ja wissen, wofür sie zuständig sind, für Block AB, AB2. Ich bin AB2. Ich glaube, die reden eher über ihr Privatleben, wenn sie mal miteinander reden, Ameisen. Ich glaube nicht, dass man sagt, oh jetzt, wo seid ihr? Ja, wir haben da diese tote Maus gefunden, die müssen wir jetzt wegarbeiten, okay.
Reden die so Telekinesisch-mässig miteinander eigentlich?
Ja, so Bienen haben ja diesen Tanz und ich glaube, Ameisen haben auch wieder Gerüche und Pheromone.
Oh, wirklich?
Cooler Tanz.
Aber es ist ein Problem, wenn die aus anderen Gebieten kommen, haben die einen Tanzdialekt und dann verstehen die kein Wort. Denken Sie, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, was, dann verstehen die kein Wort. Denken sie, was, was, was, was, was, was? Kome? Kome? Nie gehört. Aber ist nicht Ameise sein, wie jedem an dem Umzug helfen, für jeden Tag deines Lebens? Im Grunde schon. Du weißt nicht, warum du was trägst, aber irgendjemand drückt dir was in die Hand und sagt, ja, das muss da hinten hin. Genau, also du bist... Wo muss es hin? Du hast aber auch nichts anderes zu tun, du hast keine gute Ausrede als Ameise, nicht zu helfen. Gewisserweise gibt es so einen sozialen Druck, Peer Pressure, Ant Pressure. Es riecht komisch, dann kriegst du dieses Blatt in die Hand gerückt und denkst dir, Blatt, also ich muss nicht alles, aber du kannst es auch nicht in Frage stellen, weil es ist schon auch, das weiß ich jetzt wirklich nicht, es gibt eine Ameisenkönigin wahrscheinlich.
Also auch das ist monarchisch-diktatorisch geregelt.
Haben die nicht so eine Räte-Republik?
Blätter-mäßig-mäßig eine was-Republik?
Ich dachte, die haben eine Räte-Republik oder sowas. Haben die nicht so eine Demokratie, so ein Senat?
Wie so ein Jedik-Kanzel.
Ich dachte, die haben sowas in der Ecke.
Kann man das mal jemandem politisch erklären, diese Star-Wars-Welt, wie die politisch funktioniert? Weil der charaktische Senat. Genau, den verstehe ich ja noch. Ja, vor allem auch so, jede Spezies hat einen Abgeordneten. Ist das denn fair? Weil ich meine, von dieser Wookie-Art gibt es dann vielleicht zehn Millionen und von diesem Feuerteufel-Schneckenmonster gibt es drei in der Welt und die haben die gleiche Stimme oder was? Das war das, was ja wieder nie klar gesagt, wie viele Stimmen die haben. Ja, aber die werden ja nicht, du meinst, du meinst, der eltergarkische Senat hat. Ich hätte auch eher verstanden, dass die nach Planeten sortiert sind. Weiß ich gar nicht. Und dann weiss ich nicht, wie viel Stimmrecht die haben. Aber ich stelle mir das so bundesratmäßig vor. Naja, und dann gibt es ja diesen Jedi-Rat, der, aber was kann der, hat der Soweto-Recht? Oh, das weiss ich nicht. Haben die so weirde Probleme? Ich glaube, die sind auch vor allem so repräsentativ. Die müssen dann bei, wenn neuer Obi aufgemacht wird, mit dem Lichtschwert so zippen, so einfach mal die Schleife durchschneiden. Und dann ja, Mace Windu schüttelt dann dem Baumarkt-Maskottchen die Hand und so, ich glaube, das ist viel repräsentativ. Aber das fände ich mal spannend, weil du kannst ja, also du kannst ja durch Kreuzung von Tieren deren Verhalten verändern, so Hunde willst du, ja, der soll möglichst aggressiv sein oder der soll sich um die Schafe kümmern, also du kannst ja eingreifen, nicht nur in die Körper der Tiere, sondern auch in ihr Verhalten. Kann man nicht zum Beispiel Ameisen so züchten, dass sie wirklich demokratisch organisiert sind?
Also ein anderes politisches System,
dass du einfach mal sagst... Ich sagte, die hören
sofort auf, Kram zu tragen.
Ja, das ist total interessant zu sehen.
Könnten wir nicht an Ameisen oder an Tieren
verschiedene Gesellschaftsmodelle
erproben, um für den Menschen
zu sehen, was funktioniert am besten? Super.
Also ein Haufen kapitalistisch, ein Haufen kommunistisch.
Gibt es denn demokratische Tiere eigentlich?
Oder ist Natur und Demokratie komplett diametral? Das wäre doch mal ein interessantes Buch, Staatsformen bei Tieren. Ja, weil ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass die Demokratie überhaupt im Tierreich vorkommt. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Weil ich glaube, die Natur, da kommt nämlich der Geist des Menschen, ist ein bisschen unnatürlich wahrscheinlich. Aber was ist denn mit so Schwärmen irgendwie so, so Fischschwarm oder so, ist das nicht, weil man sagt ja Schwarmintelligenz, ist das nicht auch sowas wie Demokratie oder so? Was bedeutet Schwarmintelligenz denn? Aber müssen Schwarm, aber du, also ich weiß es nicht, vor allem glaube ich, dass im Tierreich zum Beispiel kranke oder nicht voll funktionsfähige Tiere generell erstmal komplett Stimmrecht verloren haben. Da hat es schon mal sowas nationalsozialistisches. Ja, das ist schwierig. Was ist zum Beispiel ein Problem im Tierreich? Und dann glaube ich nicht, dass du, also wie wir haben, so eine parlamentarische Demokratie ist ja gar nicht möglich. Weil hast du schon mal Abgeordnete aus dem Tierreich irgendwo gesehen? Das ist schwierig, ja. Außer auf der Archenoa. Was ist denn die grösste, also es gibt ja dann so Rudel, das sind dann so 20 oder so, dann so einen Bienenstock, das sind dann vielleicht 1000, aber ja, da könnte man schon eine Staatsform etablieren oder so, so ein Schwarm. Fände ich mal interessant, das ist ein Buch, da würde ich mal durchblättern, da würde ich mal den Klappentext lesen, glaube ich. Demokratie bei Geierperlhühnern. So, da haben wir es doch. Geierperlhühner haben die Demokratie erfunden, oder? Demokratie bei Geierperlhühnern, keine Macht dem Monopol. Die Vögel sorgen für einen sozialen und fairen Wettbewerb innerhalb der Gruppe und treffen obendrein noch demokratische Entscheidungen. Was müssen die denn entscheiden, diese Geierperlen? Naja, ob wir jetzt da hinten zum Strauch gehen oder doch lieber hier im Schatten bleiben. Eine Horde schwarz schimmernder Geierperlhühner versammelt sich unter der siedenden Sonne der kenianischen Savanne. Die siedende Sonne der kenianischen Savanne. Die anmutigen Vögel fallen mit ihren roten Augen, die von blassblauen Schädeln umrahmt werden und ihrem, ist das ein Gedicht, und ihrem leuchtend kobaltfarbenen Gefieder schon von weitem auf. Ich kenne kein Wort. Vielleicht hast du einen falschen Job geholt, mein Freund. Vielleicht hätte es der Autor werden sollen. Aber nicht nur wegen ihres extravaganten Äusseren. Sie bewegen sich ausschließlich in grossen Gruppen fort, mit bis zu 60 Tieren. Innerhalb der Gruppen herrscht derweil eine klare Hackordnung. Wie bei Wölfen und Menschenaffen können die dominanten Gruppenmitglieder andere den Zugang zu guten Futterquellen versperren oder sie vertreiben, wenn es um die Fortpflanzung geht. Mit dem Unterschied, dass hier Gruppenmitglieder das Alphatier durchaus in Frage stellen dürfen. In einer aktuellen Studie leben die Tiere nicht nur in einer mehrschichtigen, grossen Gesellschaft, sondern treffen Entscheidungen in der Gruppe demokratisch, auch gegen den Willen der Alphatiere. Toll, wow, das haben sie mit vielen Stunden Videomaterial und GPS-Tracking verschiedener Gruppen durchgeführt. Abstimmung per Flügelschlag? Nein. Aber wenn jetzt rauskommt, dass der T-Rex ein demokratischer Kackloser war. Demokratosaurus Rex. Aber Moment mal, also, aber hat, das ist so wie das Applausometer, oder was? Auf welchem Baum sich eine Gruppe niederlässt, darüber wird abgestimmt, per Flügelschlag. Wenn es um Flugrichtungen geht, hebt ein Teil der Gruppe demonstrativ die Flügel in die Richtung, in die geflogen werden soll. Wenn es andere Vögel eher in eine andere Richtung zieht, beispielsweise nach Norden, gut, jetzt hätte man auch Westen, Süden oder Osten schreien, beispielsweise nach Norden, gut, jetzt hat man sich hier klar entschieben, beispielsweise nach Norden. Damit der Leser merkt, das ist eine offensichtlich schlechte Idee, warum sollte man nach Norden? Nach Norden, so vollidioten. Genau, in dieser Dump-Speech geschrieben, so kleines N, grosses O. So zeigt der Flügel dorthin, wer die Mehrheit auf seiner Seite hat, gewonnen. Das ist eine demokratische Entscheidung. Das ist ja fantastisch. Du hast ja noch mal Perlhühner. Geierperlhühner. Nein, Perlhühner, verkackte. Also das ist Geierperlhuhn, also es ist gleichzeitig ein Geier und ein Huhn oder was? Und Perle. Ja, du kannst doch nicht, wie fucking faul kann man denn sein als Biologe? Hör auf, hör mal auf? Du kannst doch nicht den Namen von anderen Tieren recyceln. Du kannst doch nicht ein anderes Tier nach einem Geier benennen. Was denken sich der Geier oder was denkt sich das Geierperlhue? Empirisch gesehen liegst du mit solchen Rants immer falsch. Wir haben auch neulich gehört, da hast du nämlich gerantet über die Benennungen von Knochen. Du hast gesagt Schlüsselbein, Bein, Bein, dann gibt es das Nasenbein, alles Bein, alles Bein, dann hast du ein bisschen 20-minütiger Rant ausgeartet. Es kommt einfach vom Gebein. Ja, aber warum heißt das Bein dann Bein? Dann überleg dir doch fürs Bein einen anderen Namen, sag doch Läufel. Ja, aber das war jetzt nur ein einziges Beispiel. Also, dein Rant ist auf Sand gebaut. Dein Rant ist wieder mal auf Sand gebaut. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich verstehe total, was du meinst. Es ist keine Oberfläche, auf der man bauen sollte. Weil? Weil Sand zu instabil ist und es wegsinkt. Weil Sand zu instabil ist. Und jetzt alle. Weil Sand zu instabil ist und es wegsinkt. Ja, okay. Okay, aber das ist doch mal spannend. Also heute haben wir was gelernt. Das ist eine interessante Idee. Wird interessant.
Wunderschöne Tiere, auch mit sehr viel Blau drin. Ehrlich gesagt sehen so viele Tiere aus. Ja, sie sehen schon auch ein bisschen wie Geier, ne? Blaugeier.
Ich sag's nochmal. Geierperlhühner.
Aber es gibt auch Perlhühner und es gibt auch Geier, oder was?
Also kannst du mir gar nicht folgen. Kannst du mir in meiner Wut überhaupt nicht einen Zentimeter folgen, dass es albern ist, ein Tier Geierperlhuhn zu nennen, wenn es schon Perlhühner und schon Geier gibt. Es gibt schon Perlhühner, aber die Frage, die sich mir jetzt stellt, ist, wenn die so explizit Geierperlhühner als die demokratische Tierart vorstellen, dann werden die Perlhühner ja nicht demokratisch sein.
Ja, absolut.
Und meine Frage ist, was sind denn Perlhühner als die demokratische Tierart vorstellen, dann werden die Perlhühner ja nicht demokratisch sein. Ja, absolut. Und meine Frage ist, was sind denn Perlhühner? Weil sonst würde man das ja nicht... Perlhühner ist die klassische Diktatur. Fucking Diktatur. Das ist, ja, oder so ein Puppet State, glaube ich. Das ist auch verschiedene Staatsformen, dass die von irgendwas anderem beherrscht werden eigentlich. Von so Termiten, die eigentlich in ihrem Gehirn leben oder sowas. Wie diese Parasiten, die es... Mir wurde, habe ich das schon erzählt in Peru, wo du gesagt hast, ich soll kein Schweinefleisch essen, weil es da diesen fucking Parasiten gibt, der die ins Hirn kriegt und dich steuert. Okay, alles Laune. Das war keine Science-Fiction-Kurzgeschichte, die du im Flugzeug gelesen hast. Das ist nicht der coolste Film, wenn so nach Folge 400 rauskommt, dass die letzten 100 Folgen von einem Parasiten gesteuert wurde. Und würde ich den Podcast dann weiter mit dem Stefan machen oder mit dem Parasiten? Kommt drauf an, dass es besser ankommt. Also wenn jetzt rauskommt, dass eines Tages der Parasit rauskriegt und sagt, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf den. Und also wie würde es dann weitergehen mit dir? Der Parasit sagt, Stefan ist too much. Ich habe auch eine Light-Version von Stefan, 20 Prozent. Das stimmt, das ist gut, ja. Ist ein bisschen billiger Twist? Bei Parasiten, also niemand hängt mehr aufeinander wie Parasit und Wirt und so. Ja gut, aber da weisst du es ja vielleicht nicht, dass so ein Parasit ... Also, woher weiss man, dass man von den Parasiten gesteuert wird? Dass man plötzlich irgendwie Unfälle hat, die untypisch sind für einen oder sowas. Dass man versucht, in andere Wesen reinzukriechen die ganze Zeit. Dass man plötzlich so eine ... Das hatte ich doch sonst nie. Parasiten sind gar nicht so uncool. Lass uns das Image von Parasiten waschen Kampagne fährt. Ich verstehe. Also in dem Moment, in dem du gegen Parasiten argumentieren kannst, weißt du, dass du nicht von einem Parasiten gestaltet bist. Ja, oder halt von einem sehr cleveren Parasiten. Verdammt. Also das ist die Frage, wie kann er uns double-crossen? Also der Parasit kriecht ins Schwein, weil der Parasit weiss, Menschen sind Schweine. Weiss ich schon nicht. Und du isst das Schwein und dann sagt der Parasit, und jetzt aus dem Magen, aus dem Magen ins Gehirn, das ist eine lange Reise. Ist die geplant?
Oder ist er so ein Hang-Lose-Guy,
der so, I'm going with the flow.
Aber wie genau, kommt er aus dem Magen,
also der muss ja, dann kriegt er dann die Speiseröhre hoch,
oder geht er direkt aus dem Magen und geht über die...
I'm peacing out. Ich mache jetzt
mein Sabbatical, ich mache jetzt mein Sabbatjahr.
Ja, Mann, wo willst du hin?
Weißt du was? Keine Ahnung. Ich weiss, du hängst
hier immer in diesem Schwein. Mir ist das scheißegal.
Menschen essen Schwein, Schwein
Vielen Dank. Sabbatical, ich mache jetzt mein Sabbatjahr. I'm peacing out. Weißt du was, keine Ahnung. Ich weiss, du hängst hier immer in diesem Schwein. Mir ist das scheißegal. Menschen essen Schwein, Schwein wird gegessen, ich kriege hoch ins Menschenhirn. Ich gucke mal, was passiert. Ich gucke, wo es mich hinträgt. Aber wir haben noch einen klaren Plan. I'm peacing out. Wir haben noch einen klaren Plan, Mann. Kannst du nicht für einen Plan abweichen? Wir gehen in den Boden, dann kommt das Schwein, wühlt da rum, wir gehen in die Schweinenase und jetzt sind wir im Schwein, das ist doch super. Weißt du was, ich mache den Job schon seit zwei Jahren, zwei Minuten, was in unserer Zeitrechnung zwei Minuten sind. Ja, Mann, ich habe schon gemerkt, dass du in letzter Zeit ein bisschen schlapp bist. Ich bin raus, ich kann das nicht mehr, ich gehe jetzt raus und seitdem ist es richtig gut, dass ich das gegessen habe. Ich glaube, das ist das Richtige für dich, ich glaube, das ist das Richtige für für dich. Und wenn ich am Ende in einem Geierperlenhuhn-Kopf lande, dann ist es... Wohin es sich treibt, Mann, wohin es sich treibt.
Ja. Okay, go with the flow.
I'm going with the flow, bye.
Bye, Mann.
Ofen.
Sagen wir mal, die Rippchen sehen aber gut aus, oder?
Lecker, schmecker.
Lecker.
Geierperlhuhn.
Ich bin ein Geierperlhuhn.
Ich bin der Fall. oder? Lecker schmecker geierperlhuhn ich bin ein geierperlhuhn ich hab die geierperlen gern das kann natürlich sein dass die geierperlhuhne heißen weil die geierperlen weil die perlengeiern meinst du? weil die auch perlengeiern auch geil ne dass also die die muschel hat einfach, macht Perlen, also die macht Schmuck. Wait a second, wait a fucking second. Diese Art geht aufs Truthuhn zurück. Aber jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Okay, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam, Welt, Welt, Welt. Nochmal einen Flügelschlag zurück. Die Welt dreht sich zu schnell für uns. Kurz mal Segel hoch,
kurz mal Fallschirm an. Also.
Wir halten alle den Flügel hoch fürs Stopp.
Stopp. Wir gucken, ja, fast alle sagen Stopp.
Warum wollt ihr nach Norden, ihr Idioten?
Fucking Norden. Ich habe gerade aus
Versehen und jetzt gern verhindert,
den Satz gelesen, das Geierperlhuhn
Du warst zu neugierig. Du bist zu
hoch geflogen. Aus der Gattung des Truthuhns. Frage Der Truthahn. Ja. Ist das männliches Truthuhn? Essen wir nur Truthahn? Es hat sich irgendwann abgespalten, dass die Hühner und die Hähne ihr eigenes Ding gemacht haben und dann wurden die Hähnen zu einer ganz eigenen Tierart wieder. Das Truthuhn ist eine Nordamerika-Beheimat-Art der Truthhühner. Jetzt kann ich auf Truthhühner auch noch klicken. Gatt und der Fasanenartige. So, jetzt reicht es mir. Das ist dieses alte Pampelmusen-Problem. Ja, genau. Das ist immer am Ende ein Kreis. Am Ende ist es ein Kreis. Am Ende ist der Vorfahren des Fasans der Geierperlhut. Du denkst dir, wie geht das? Also Truthuhden versus Truthahn. Ach, sind Truthahn? Aber Pute. Ist Pute und Truthahn das Gleiche? Wir haben wirklich so ein Mandarinen-Grapefruit-Problem jetzt. Nein, es gibt den Put-Hahn und das Put-Huden. Und das ist eine Mischung aus Huhn und Pute. Keine Angst, Leute, nicht wütend werden oder so. Wir erklären das nämlich jetzt. Die Pute auch Haus Truthuhn ist die domizierte Form des Truthuhns. Ich komme mir gerade vor wie diesen Mandela-Effekt. Das Wort Truthahn existiert offensichtlich nicht. Nee, du bist der einzige, der jedes Wort ..., Truthahn oder Welchhahn genannt.
Truth-Henne.
Okay, wir haben es geklärt.
Truthahn ist die männliche Version von Truth-Huhn.
Wir essen wahrscheinlich Truth-Hühner.
Oder nennt man das dann Put?
Was sind dann Truth-Puten?
Aber kommt Truth von Put?
Also Put-Hahn?
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Also Put-Hahn, Truth-Hahn, Truth-H Jetzt halte ich mal zurück mit deinen Korri-Fragen. Naja, gut. Aber wir kriegen das, wir haben es denn gekriegt. Wir haben es denn gekriegt. Aber es war kurz aufregend. Wir haben uns kurz gefragt, was essen wir da eigentlich? Aber Pute und Truthahn ist nicht dasselbe, oder? Oder ist Pute weiblicher Truthahn? Ich habe immer das Gefühl, die Matrix hat so weirde Lacks gerade. Ja, wir haben den neuesten Patch noch nicht irgendwie. Weil ich war auch immer, war ich im Radio, das Radio angemacht und es lief dieser Song, Head and Shoulders, Knees and Toes, my bones, dieser Popsong. Ja. Und da dachte ich mir, so, jetzt, so, Matrix, jetzt ist es vorbei. Aber wenn jetzt so Popsongs anfangen, Head and Shoulders, Knees and Toes, Knees and Toes zu singen und das verkauft mir die Matrix jetzt als der neue Popsong, den alle Leute hören und im Club abgehend so Head and Shoulders, Knees and Toes, End Toes, dann denke ich mir, so, einfach mal Stopp. Das ist einfach ein Remaster von einem alten, ja. Ich verstehe, was du meinst.
Das fand ich so albern, mir das jetzt zu verkaufen, nur weil gerade das neue Patch nicht geladen war. Für meinen Stefan geht ins Radio. Da haben die Entwickler offensichtlich einfach, mussten Leute entlassen und konnten sich keine neuen Sachen überlegen. Das ist dann wie der neue Hint der Biba Butzemann, der irgendwie in den Clubs von Deutschland oben runter runter gespielt hat. Biba Butzemann, Biba Butzemann, Biba Butzemann, ich bin ein Trudhuhn. Was meinst du, wann steigen Leute einfach aus der Kultur aus? Also sagen, das ist das, ich habe da keinen Bock mehr. Ich habe das hier schon peu à peu. Also ich habe keine Lust mehr. Ich schaue keine Filme an, ich schaue keine Serien mehr an, ich höre keine Musik mehr, das ist mir alles, das ist alles Quatsch, das ist alles immer das Gleiche, so ich höre auf, ich gehe raus.
Ja, aber bei der Musik habe ich aufgehört, bei der neuen Musik habe ich aufgehört. Du hörst keine neue Musik mehr.
Ja, nach Head and Shoulders, Knees and Toast, Knees and Toast ist es vorbei.
Es war schon kurz bei diesem einen Song, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie der geht, aber wo der Refrain irgendwie nur war, ich mag Musik, lalalalalala, also Mark Forster-artiger Song, muss ich nochmal genau recherchieren.
Ja, ich nicht, wenn ich das höre. Ja, genau, man denkt so, nee, das ist alles nur zu faul, weil Musik, wenn Musik zu selbstreferenziell wird. Und jetzt bei Head and Steuers in Toss bin ich raus so ein bisschen und höre dann eher, also ich glaube, jeder Song, den ich noch hören werde in meinem Leben, wurde bereits geschrieben. Außer so Filme, wo ich es nicht beurteilen kann. Du hast gar kein Vertrauen mehr in die Musikindustrie? Nein, nein, nein. Auch nicht mal in andere Länder gucken oder so? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Was ja nur in anderen Ländern geht oder so, guckst du gar nicht rein? Gar nicht rein. Ich bin da stark jetzt aus. Also die Musik wurde bereits geschrieben. Was ist denn dann, also wir haben ja schon lange den Kampf zwischen zwei Gedankengebäuden. Sozialismus, Kapitalismus. Nee, und zwar der ewige Kampf zwischen künstlicher Intelligenz und Random. Ich habe ja gesagt, die Zukunft liegt im Zufall, du hast gesagt, die Zukunft liegt in künstlicher Intelligenz. Das weiß ich nicht. Doch, wir hatten eine Diskussion und du hast gesagt, in Zukunft wird die Musik alles von künstlicher Intelligenz geschrieben, wird Artikel werden geschrieben und alles. Und ich habe gesagt, nein, Zufall ist besser als KI. Und jetzt, Achtung, gab es, habe ich diese Woche entdeckt, eine ganz fantastische Seite. Und zwar, da können wir uns mal angucken, wie gut Künstliche Intelligenz funktioniert. Und zwar gibt es eine Webseite, in der man einen Twitter-Account einspeisen kann. Und er schaut sich alle Tweets an von diesem Account und generiert neue Tweets auf Grundlage dieser KI. So, und ich habe es mir
natürlich nicht nehmen lassen, mal ein
paar Stefan-Tietze-Tweets
zu machen. Und
das war eine grosse Freude.
Moment, okay,
der liest sich, du speist
Tweets ein oder speist er sich alle Tweets?
Genau, ich gebe einfach nur den Twitter-Händler an,
der liest alle Tweets aus,
nehme ich mal an, sodass es so
funktioniert, und auf der Grundlage davon
Vielen Dank. Tweets ein oder speist er sich alle Tweets? Genau, ich gebe einfach nur den Twitter-Händler an, der liest alle Tweets aus, so nehme ich mal an, sodass es so funktioniert, und auf der Grundlage davon generiert er neue Tweets, die sozusagen von dir sein könnten. Problem, jetzt kann die KI ja wahrscheinlich nicht entscheiden oder differenzieren zwischen den Tweets, die ich als Gag raushaue, die schlechten Gags, die ich aus Ironie raushaue und die Werbung für eigene Projekte, die oft keinen Witz beinhalten, die wo ich sage, die nächste Show von Tietz und Will ist am 19.9. Korrekt. Okay. Okay, ich fange mal an mit dem ersten Tweet und da merkt man schon, oh, einen wichtigen Persönlichkeitsaspekt von Stefan wurde hier direkt erfasst, nämlich Stefan liebt das Reisen. So, der erste Tweet lautet, sechstausend Jahre Kulturgeschichte in einem Stadtteil, zehn Städte, sechs Kulturen, viele Geschichten, viele Möglichkeiten, ein Blick auf den Tag. Sechstausend Jahre Kulturgeschichte in einem Stadtteil, zehn Städte, sechs Kulturen, viele Geschichten, viele Möglichkeiten, ein Blick auf den Tag. Also es klingt so, als würdest du so ein Reisetagebuch machen. Ja, aber Moment mal, ich habe ja quasi Peru, mein Peru-Trip, die letzte Reise, die habe ich begleitet mit gewissen geschichtlichen Hintergründen, ein paar Informationen zu den Leuten und der Stadt. Das war Instagram, das war nicht Twitter. Twitter habe ich noch nie irgendwas von einer Reise geschrieben. Spannend. Aber anscheinend hat diese KI das rausgefunden. Und kein Humor. Da habe ich Liebe diese Also von der Form könnte es Sinn ergeben, aber inhaltlich zehn Städte, sechs Kulturen, viele Geschichten, viele Möglichkeiten, ein Blick
auf den Tag. Also es klingt so, als käme
da jetzt noch der Link zu deinem Reiseteilgebuch.
Es hat meinen Rhythmus.
Es hat deinen Rhythmus, ja. Sehr schön mag ich auch
den Tweet, kannst du ja mal vorlesen.
Ich habe den Grossteil meines Lebens
gespielt auf dem Boden, jede Minute,
jede Sekunde.
Ich habe den Grossteil meines Lebens gespielt auf dem Boden. Jede Minute, jede Sekunde. Ja, stark. Aber den finde ich auch sehr schön. Stark. Ich wünsche euch allen einen wunderbaren Sonntag. Das klingt wie ein Pfarrer. Der ist so gut. Der klingt wie ein Pfarrer. Ich wünsche euch allen einen wunderbaren Sonntag. Vor allem nach diesen Nonsens-Tweets. Und ich denke, okay. Wow. Es ist wirklich fantastisch. Tweethunter.io heißt das Ganze. Tweethunter. Okay, nächste Woche machen wir das mit deinem Twitter-Account. Das finde ich super. Aber das ist ja absolut genial. Vor allem, ich denke mir, was würde passieren, wenn man wirklich mal einen Monat nur in diesem absoluten Nonsens tweeten würde? Also würden die Leute irgendwann wirklich einen Arzt rufen und sagen, da stimmt was nicht? Ich glaube, die würden sehr schnell darauf kommen, dass man so eine KI... Aber ich finde das Wort KI mal so weird ein bisschen. Weil inzwischen mit alles als Artificial Intelligence oder KI beschrieben und so, aber es ist einfach ein dusseliger Ja, es ist einfach dusselig, aber ich mag es vor allem immer, wenn gewisse Tweet-Formate aufgegriffen werden, wie zum Beispiel das Format der Liste. Hier zum Beispiel haben wir einen Tweet in Listenform von Stefan. Erstens, ich kaufe Schirm. Zweitens, ich kaufe mächtige Tassen. Mächtige Tassen? Das ist ein geiler Bandname. Drittens, ich kaufe einen neuen Laptop. Viertens, ich kaufe einen neuen Fahrrad. Fünftens, ich kaufe ein neues Auto. Sechstens, ich. Warte, warte, warte, ist das fantastisch?
Was macht, ach so, das ist wirklich ein Tweet von mir.
Ich habe den Befehl für die Zukunft in der gleichen Sprache wie den Befehl, nein, es ist kein Bild gemacht.
Ja, das sind die Tweets, die wir von Stefan kennen.
Ich weiss, dass ich selbst alleine nicht so gut bin, als dass ich so gerne eine Woche lang dran wäre.
Das finde ich schon gut. Ich wäre wirklich nicht so gerne eine Woche dran, weil ich nicht so gut bin. Ich finde selber, dass ich nicht so gut bin, dass ich nicht so gerne eine Woche dran. Das ist ja absolut fantastisch. Aber ich muss sagen, wenn man da drauf guckt, nur das Bild sieht, was du mir gerade gezeigt hast, viele Tweets auf einer Seite, das sieht total so weit aus, als wäre es mein Twitter-Account. Ja, total. Also auf den ersten Blick ist es gut. Ich habe auch meinen mal eingegeben und finde natürlich immer gut, wenn, wie gesagt, diese Formate benutzt werden. Hier haben wir zum Beispiel eines, das so formatiert ist wie ein Tweet, den man kennen könnte. Okay, in eckigen Klammern WhatsApp. Jemand? Hey, kannst du mir schon mal ein neues Bild hinzufügen? Ich, ja, wie, er ging Klammern als Action Text, fällt mit einem kleinen Foto auf jemand, haha ja.
Also wir haben hier, also diese KI hat gecheckt, dass es eine Dialogform ist zwischen zwei Figuren, nämlich jemand und ich, und das hält es auch konstant durch.
Auf WhatsApp?
Auf WhatsApp, und dazwischen kommen immer Regieanweisungen. WhatsApp, jemand, hey, kannst du mir schon mal ein neues Bild hinzufügen? Ich, ja. Regieanweisung, fällt mit einem kleinen Foto auf, jemand, haha ja. Also es ergibt Faszin. Aber ich liebe die Regieanweisung, fällt mit einem kleinen Foto auf. Da steckt so viel Verachtung in diesem Text. Vor allem, du hast eine Art subjektive Regieanweisung, er fällt auf mit etwas, wem denn? Also das ist ganz fantastisch. Da kann man richtig viel Spaß mit haben, Tweet Hunter heißt das Ganze. Und ja, ich glaube, ich muss dir da ein bisschen Recht geben, denn KI könnte die Zukunft sein. Weil irgendwann, du musst ja nur noch hundert Tweets schreiben in deinem Leben, und ab dann übernimmt ja die KI. Nee, ich bin gar nicht so weit weg von dir, glaube ich. Ich behaupte, dass das die Zukunft ist. Ich glaube aber, dass Willkür eine große Rolle in unserem Leben spielt, weil alles vorhergesehen ist, ausrechenbar ist irgendwann und so, und alles algorithmusgesteuert und zahlenbasiert und so. Und deswegen glaube ich, habe ich total viel Spaß an randomisierten Dingen. Weil plötzlich sind wirkliche Dinge wahnsinnig wichtig. Ich meine, wir hören, Radio ist ja auch ein bisschen so ein Randomizer. Du hörst die ganze Zeit Songs, die du schon kennst, bei Spotify, hast deine Playlists, hast deine Künstler. Ach so, das meinst du mit Radio. Und dann ist Radio ja auch in so in gewisser Weise so ein Random Aspekt, den man sich gerade total, ich freue mich manchmal total darauf, Radio einzuschalten und irgendwas kommt. Irgendwer redet über irgendwas, irgendein Song kommt. Hier ist der peruanische Pan-Flötenkünstler Pedro Bombardier und ballert einen Song raus. Pedro Pan. Und ich denk mir so, geil! Und heute ist der Tag der Leberwurst. Und wir hören jetzt mal damals, wie Frank Leber das angebaut hat in seinem Feld. Dann denke ich mir, das will ich doch hören. Frank Leber. So, das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Auf jeden Fall. Und ich glaube, das ist immer mehr ein erstrebenswerter Zustand. Ja. Es ist schon krass, wir haben auch oft den Link bekommen mit dem KI-generiertenog zwischen Werner Herzog und Slavoj Zizek, sehr, sehr cool. Es klingt auch gar nicht so schlecht, also so von der Sprachmelodie und so ist da schon was drin, findet ihr im Reddit. Ich habe einen Tweet noch generiert, und zwar weil ich mir dachte, vielleicht funktioniert das besser auf Englisch, weil der wahrscheinlich eine grössere Erfahrungsschatz auf Englisch hat, deswegen habe ich auch mal meinen, ich habe vor langer, langer Zeit meinen englischen Twitter-Account gehabt und habe ich auch mal eingespeist und ich finde, das ist dabei rausgekommen. I wanna grow up to be just like my grandpa, who is just like me. Das ist doch vergleichsweise nah an einem echten Gag, oder? I wanna grow up to be just like my grandpa, who was just like me. Also das ist ja fast, also das funktioniert ja fast schon. Ja, ich will mir treu bleiben. Also das ist ja eine gute Aussage. Ja. Also das ist auch lustig, ist auch eine klassische Gagform. Also das könnte man ja in einem Gag umarbeiten. Mein größter Traum ist es, so zu sein wie Jonah Hill, weil die Leute immer sagen, ich bin wie er, irgendwie sowas. Also das kann man ja, das kann man ja umsetzen. Also die Grund, es es ist gar nicht so schlecht, so als Grundidee, um daraus was zu machen. Ja, ja, finde ich auch super. Also es kann ja auch sein, dass das einfach als Inspiration dient in Zukunft, dass du, wenn du ein Drehbuch schreibst und du hast keine Ahnung, du einfach eine KI, eine Idee generieren lässt und das dann so als Inspiration nimmst und kogst, ja, das und das kann man nutzen, weil das ist so verrückt, da hätte man vielleicht gar nicht selber drauf gucken können. Also ich habe neulich auch entdeckt, da gibt es auch zum Rollenspielen, so quasi so Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspielen, gibt so KIs inzwischen, wo man sagen kann, in welchem Abenteuerart das ganze spielen soll, also welches Szenario spielt man, welches Setting spielt man, es ist so medieval, England, Cyberpunk, was auch immer, kannst du eingeben, oder Fantasy, ganz normal, DSA-Style, und dann kannst du beschreiben, was passiert, und die KI spinnt das weiter. Das ist eine Website, die möchte ich jetzt noch nicht nennen, weil ich habe das Gefühl, das könnte in den nächsten Folgen mal spannend sein, wenn wir das machen. und unsere Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer werden das nicht finden können, wenn du es ihnen nicht nennst.
Doch, ich sag's euch, AI Dungeon heißt das, wahrscheinlich kennen das auch viele schon, macht ja auch keinen Sinn, das euch nicht zu sagen. Aber ich fände es cool, wenn wir das in der nächsten Folge mal spielen, um mal ein kleines Abenteuer hier zu spielen, mit einer KI, weil ich glaube, es ist spannend. Ich weiß nicht, ob das alles KIs sind, ich glaube, es sind einfach nur clevere Algorithmen, ich glaube, es ist selbstlernende. Ja ja gut, das sei die Frage, was das genau ist. Weil wir haben auch schon oft so KI-generierte Folgen von uns bekommen oder so und ich denke mir immer so, das ist gefakt. Ich denke mir immer sofort, das ist gefakt, weil wie soll das gehen? Aber das ist natürlich auch so dieses Uncanny Valley, durch das wir durch müssen, dass man immer denkt, nee, das stimmt so nicht, aber vielleicht irgendwann doch. Ich meine, es gibt 300 Folgen von uns, vielleicht ist es wirklich irgendwann genug, dass man einfach sagt, lass uns eine neue Folge generieren. Ich meine, was man machen könnte, das ist jetzt natürlich viel Communityarbeit erforderlich, aber alle Folgen transkribieren. Alle 333 Folgen transkribieren. Weil dann hat man einen gewissen Messwert, glaube ich, mit dem man arbeiten kann, den in eine coole Textgenerations-AI reinzuspallern. Was meinst du mit cool? Eine gute, most advanced, für die man auch so zahlen muss, weil das sind, glaube ich, die richtig guten. So, und dann können wir das einsprechen mal in einer der nächsten hundert Folgen, wir sagen aber nicht welche, und ihr müsst herausfinden, welche AI generiert. Stimmt, guter Punkt, ja. Eine der nächsten Folgen wird AI generiert sein, ihr müsst herausfinden, welche. Ja, aber erst, wenn ihr alle Folgen transkribiert habt. Ja, und wir auf der Grundlage. Nur, dass wir weiterarbeiten können, der Ball liegt gerade bei euch. Ich sag das immer gern. Wenn es nicht passiert, ist es eure Schuld. Genau. Ihr müsst euch drum kümmern. Der Ball liegt auf eurer Seite des Spielfelds. Genau, hebtbt ihn auf und macht einen Aufschlag. Macht was damit. Wir spielen ihn schlaff zurück, sodass ihr noch mal richtig drauf machen könnt. Wir sind hier. Wir sind schon da. Wir sind da. Wir sind Teil des Spiels. Wir sind da. Aktuell sitzen wir auf der Bank. Kurz durchschnaufen, aber an sich, wir sind schon in der Nähe. Genau. Sehr gut. Das finde ich eine sehr gute Idee. Ach, es ist nicht so, dass das Projekt einschläft. Es bekommen noch Ideen. Wir haben noch Ideen, wie wir Arbeit vermeiden können. Wir haben noch drei Ideen. Wir haben noch drei, vier Ideen. Ja, aber die sind richtig gut. Also freut euch auf die nächsten 300 Folgen. Die sind absolut fantastisch. Ne, finde ich klasse. Machen wir. Also zum Ende der Folge hast du noch ein paar Tipps. Ich habe noch ganz viele Tipps. Schaut, dass euer Kühlschrank nicht konstant unter Wasser steht, sonst schimmelt er langsam. Das ist mein Tipp. Und ansonsten, Knoblauch, Salz direkt aufs Brot, warum nicht? Okay, auf welches Brot? Das ist euch überlassen. Nee, weil du musst keinen Tipp geben. Wenn du keinen hast, ist es nicht sagt. Ja, aber nein, ihr könnt das, also wenn ihr kein Brot habt, könnt ihr auch Brot durch eure Zunge ersetzen. Also ihr könnt direkt Knoblauchsalz auf also direkt auf eure Zunge raus. Direkt in den Mund rein kippen. Direkt in den Mund. Ich hatte ein Riesenproblem mit meinem Knoblauchsalz, da ist, glaube ich, irgendwann einfach ein Stück Wasser reingeflogen oder so und das hat sich dann verkrustet wie so eine Perle, wie bei Muscheln, wo ja so ein Stück Dreck drin ist. Wie eine Geierperle. Genau, aus allem ja, alles Schöne fängt mit was Hässlichem an. Das ist ja die Botschaft der Muschel. Der Geierperle. Da muss ja Dreck rein und um den Dreck herum ist da eine wunderschöne Perle. So wie wenn das Leben, wenn einem was Schlechtes passiert, denkt, das ist so der Dreck und jetzt baut die Perle drumherum. Wenn man ja meint, dass Leuten, denen es schlechter geht, bessere Perlen bauen. Ist das nicht so? Der Ball liegt auf deiner Seite? Ich wünschte, er wäre es nicht, aber ich würde den Zurückspiel mit einem klaren Nein. Okay, also die Muschel hat Unrecht. Du sagst, du, das sprieweg. Ich finde, die Muschel ist eine schöne Metapher. Ja, okay. Also jetzt für dieses ... Ja klar, Diamanten müssen erst Druck ausgesetzt sein, um Diamanten zu werden. Pressure makes Diamonds. Ja. Dirt makes pearls. Und deswegen gibst du dir Salz direkt in die Fresse rein. Und deswegen, ich hatte ein ähnliches. So, da fehlen ein paar Schritte. Ehrlich gesagt war das in etwa der Weg. Aber gut. Und deswegen hatte ich jetzt ein ähnliches Problem, dass Wasser in meinen Knoblauchsalzstreuer gekommen ist. Und dann ist er so innen so verklumpt. Und ich weiß auch nicht, wie das geht, dass er immer größer klumpt. Das war wie so ein Schneeball in dem Knoblauchsalzstreuer drin. Und jetzt hatte ich da irgendwann so einen riesigen Brocken, der fast größer war als die Dose selber. Das hat physikalisch überhaupt gar keinen Sinn ergeben. Und dann habe ich nichts mehr rausbekommen. Bis ich gesagt habe, so, jetzt kommt der Kaiserschnitt, jetzt muss was passieren, habe den Streuer aufgeschnitten und hatte dann einfach diesen massiven
Block. Aber hast du überlegt, den einfach mal
in so einen Apfel reinzubeissen?
So, und
jetzt kommen wir an den Punkt,
wo ich nicht mehr so stolz
bin auf mich, weil ich mir
dachte, geil, jetzt habe ich hier diesen Salzblock,
Knoblauchsalz, und dann habe ich
den weggeleckt wie ein Lolli.
Klar, das verstehe ich, aber komplett. Wie so ein Lolli. Klar, das verstehe ich aber komplett.
Wie so ein Pferd, so ein Salzstein.
Absolut komplett.
Geil, also coole Erfahrung.
Also, ich sage mal so,
ich finde ja ohnehin,
die herbe Seite der Snacks
ist unterrepräsentiert.
Aber das ist genetisch bedingt, habe ich erfahren.
In meinem DNA-Test, den ich mal gemacht habe,
steht drin, dass ich eher salzige Snacks
auch mag, also eher herbere
Desserts. Also ich würde eher den
Vielen Dank. Genesisch bedingt habe ich erfahren, in meinem DNA-Test, den ich mal gemacht habe, steht drin, dass ich eher salzige Snacks auch mag, also eher herbere Desserts. Also ich würde eher den Käseteller nehmen als die Creme Brulee. Ich würde eher die Chips essen, die Pringles, als eine Tafel Rittersport. Weißt du? Das ist genesisch bedingt. Ich würde eher die Grissini als die Haribos. Okay. Wo ist Lakritze dann? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Eher süss, ne? Also das ist keine gute Frage. Einfach sehr süss. Okay, ja dann. Du, ich brauche dein Feedback auch manchmal. Also halt dein Feedback nicht zurück, ich brauche das auch. Nee. Aber das ist genetisch, das kann man nachgucken. Du kannst Genanalyse machen machen und dann wissen ... Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das die Pseudowissenschaft ist, aber das steht als Character Traits drin. Und ich sehe mich da schon drin wieder. Das heißt, für dich wäre ideal, weil zum Beispiel einen Lolli kannst du nicht nutzen. Weil es gibt keine herben Lollis. Ich meine, das ist sehr selbstbewusst geschrieben auf dieser Website. Da steht Haare, wahrscheinlich dunkelblond. Sommersprossen, wahrscheinlich keine. Snacks, die er will, herb. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das genau so, weil es geschrieben ist, einfach wie klare körperliche Traits. Ich glaube aber, das ist eher noch so ein bisschen Pseudowissenschaft. Ich finde das verrückt, dass das so die Vorliebe. Ich meine, das ist noch nicht ein Kinderschuh, das sind jetzt winzige kleine Schuhe, die lächerlich klein sind, wo man denkt, da passen menschliche Füsse rein. Nein, winzige Kindermassageschuhe, Kinderfussmassageschuhe. Kindermassagesessel. Da haben wir doch ein Produkt. Jetzt haben wir ein Produkt. Jetzt haben wir ein Produkt, ein Kindermassagesessel. Ich bin ja dafür, dass du mit so einem Kindermassage, mobile Kindermassage-Van. So ein Van, ja. Kindermassage zwei Euro. Uiuiuiui. Nein, es ist nicht verboten. Hoppala. Es ist nicht verboten. Können wir nicht mal bitte. Kannst du nicht bitte. Können wir das in dem Podcast machen? Wir melden ein Gewerbe an, wir tun so, wir gehen jeden, wir tun so. Nein, aber wir können, Satire. Aber auf was? Auf was Satire, auf was? Nee, ich will nur herausfinden, ob es in Deutschland möglich ist, ein Gewerbe als mobile Kindermassage wie so ein Foodtruck, Massagetruck. Aber alles ab 18 wird abgelehnt. Ja, ja. Also in diesem Anmeldung, in der Gewerbeanmeldung ist es möglich, eine mobile Kindermassage in einem Van? Ich habe noch nie was von Kindermassage gehört und ich habe in einer heilpädagogischen Tagesstelle gearbeitet. Da wurde alles versucht, damit es den Kindern besser geht. Auf Pferden reiten, über Therapie, verschiedene Sachen. Und ich habe noch nie was von Massage gehört. Nein, nein, das war ja auch, nein, das gibt es ja auch nicht. Also hoffentlich nicht. Weiß ich nicht. Aber nein, nein, nein. So, aber was ich meine ist, die Forschung steckt noch in den Kinderschuhen. Das heißt, irgendwann könnte man jetzt ja noch weiterentwickeln, dass man nicht nur sagt, herb oder süss, sondern dass du genau den richtigen Snack genetisch bedingt dir auslesen lassen kannst. Also dass du genau sagst, weisses Duplo ist genau genetisch präzise genau das Produkt, das du haben willst. Das ist ja die Zukunft. Also ist das nicht ein Problem, weil aktuell viele Industrien
beruhen auf Werbung. Ihr macht das nicht den Markt
kaputt, also macht das nicht die Marktwirtschaft kaputt,
weil plötzlich Dinge nicht mehr in Konkurrenz einander stehen,
sondern ja quasi in genetischer Kampf ausbricht.
Also Dinge, die wir
Ja und du brauchst keine Werbung
mehr, weil die Leute ja genau das
wissen, was sie genau wollen. Das heißt,
wenn ein neues Produkt rauskommt,
gehst du zum Arzt, spuckst dem
in den Mund, dann macht er eine Genanalyse
Das ist ein bitter, ja. Nee, nee, nicht bitter. Die normale Vollmilchschokolade von Rittersport. Aber ich meine, viele, viele, viele... Das ist ja Tellereis. Vanilleeis. Lieblingsgeschmack Milch. Milch? So, und dann, weil ich glaube, viele Teile der Industrie beruhen ja auf Werbung, Entertainment ist ja undenkbar ohne Werbung und wenn Werbung komplett wegbricht, dann haben ganz viele Unterhaltungsbereiche ein Riesenproblem. Also ich würde da echt aufpassen mit dieser Gentechnik. Es bricht nicht Werbung weg, sondern es gibt ja immer noch die Hersteller für diese Dinge dann jetzt.
Also da gibt es ja eine Firma mit so einem Gerät, was sie die Augen, die Retina scannt und dann unten kommt Hubba Bubba
raus. So, das
Dingen muss ja auch vermarktet
werden. Du kannst dich ja für
das Apple-Gerät
entscheiden oder für das Medion-Gerät.
Und dafür muss ja auch Werbung
gemacht werden. Es gibt ja, weißt du, es gibt ja dann
eine Sekundärindustrie.
Es gibt ja immer, immer Gegenstände für den Endverbraucher, die wahrscheinlich vermarktet werden müssen. Und dann, dafür können wir wieder Werbung machen, mit unserem Podcast, denen aber nur Leute hören, die den verschrieben bekommen vom Arzt. Ja, oder es läuft halt andersrum, dass die Produkte direkt auf Grundlage des Gencodes hergestellt werden. Weil wenn in dem Gencode steht, ob du süss oder herb magst, dann muss es ja möglich sein, in eine Maschine bei Haribo deinen Gencode einzuspeisen und der erstellte Produkt, also dann steht dann Form Pinguin, Geschmack Honig. Aber jetzt habe ich eine biologische Frage. Wie weit geht denn, ist denn der Gen-Code? Wenn da jetzt drinsteht, ich mag herbe Süssigkeiten, also herben Nachtisch, dann steht da ja nicht. Und vielleicht gibt es sogar so Rezeptoren, Bitterstoffe mag ich lieber als andere Menschen und so weiter.
Aber wie konkret wird denn DNA?
Ja, das ist jetzt natürlich die Frage.
Weil no way, dass es dann bis zu Faktor drei einem sagt, wie genau man schmeckt.
Naja, wenn es heißt, du hast halt keine Ahnung, so und so viele, diese Art von Proteine reagiert auf diese Art von Geschmacksstoff und du hast da so und so viel davon, eine Mischung oder was auch immer in deinen Geschmacksknospen, keine Ahnung, könnte man vielleicht schon genau deine Aufstellung an verschiedenen Enzymen, Proteinen, was auch immer haben und dann kann man sagen, es gibt ja diese Formel, dass man sagt so 75% Kohlenhydrate, 25% Fett ist so perfekt und das kannst du ja dann nochmal präziser steuern auf genau dich. Und dann drückst du da auf den Knopf und dann kommt genau dein Honigpinguin raus. Der Knopf hat die Farbe, die du am liebsten magst. Genau. Und dann kommt genau deine Packung Honigpinguine raus, die genau du, genau perfekt magst. Genau für dich. Also du magst sie so gern. Ich liebe meine Honigpinguine. Ich liebe sie so gern. Alle wissen das auch. Alle wissen Stefan nur die Konigpinguine. Jeden Morgen, jeden Abend. Die Koriander-Honig-Pinguine. Und dann kommt der Nächste, drückt auf den Knopf, spuckt in die Maschine, drückt auf den Knopf und dann kriegt er seine Packung. Und dann brauchst du ja gar keine Werbung oder sowas mehr. Also ich mache mir da richtige Probleme. Ich glaube, wir haben in den nächsten Jahren noch einiges zu tun, a mit KI, mit Random und aber auch mit Genanalyse. Ich glaube, das wird noch mal einiges zum Umsturz bringen. Und ich freue mich, da durch diese wilde Zeit mit euch durchzuleben, ihr Lieben. Ja, ihr Lieben, ey, passt mir mal auf, ihr Lieben. Passt mal auf. Nee, nee, einfach so generell.
Beware.
Beware, seid wach, schaut mal, was so passiert um mich herum.
Weil ich habe auch vor manchen Trends Angst.
Also davor habe ich jetzt zum Beispiel Angst.
Weil ich glaube, ich brichte alles zusammen.
Und ich glaube auch, da müssen wir ein bisschen Abstand von nehmen.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht so wahnsinnig hilfreich diese Richtung.
Ist auch ein schönes Schlusswort von Stefan Tietze, der sagt Augen auf und dann hören wir uns noch nichts.
Passt mal auf, aber ich sag's so, als würde man denken, dass danach noch was kommt.
Passt mal auf.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche, bis dahin, macht's gut, wir eben ab, ciao!